bien des jeunes de son âge louis seize
ans est un adepte de jeux vidéo et
encore plus depuis le début de la
pandémie les amis je les vois sur les
jeux vidéo j'en parle en juin puis vu
coeur peut plus faire grand chose parce
que tout est fermé belge c'est sûr que
je joue plus en 2020 grâce aux revenus
son emploi d'été ils multiplient les
achats virtuels en jeu je me dis oh
c'est juste vingt pièces mettaient 20
pièces à chaque jour à chaque demi heure
de la journée que je dépensais plus de
deux cents en quelques mois trois mille
dollars s'envolent en fumée
uniquement dans des jeux vidéo
l'adolescent a dépensé tout son argent
avec un compte paypal liées à son compte
des pagnes des jardins paypal exige
pourtant que ses utilisateurs et 18 ans
mais louis dit n'avoir eu aucune
difficulté à ouvrir son compte les jo le
mollah me lebel and it mais c'était pas
du temps ben à fond tu peux mettre ce
que tu veux le defender le ton qu'on
décret en tête s'émeut des mois
auparavant
son père avait pourtant avisé paypal que
son fils n'avait pas l'âge requis
je voulais faire fermer ce conteneur
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
ils pouvaient acheter n'importe quoi
j'ai écrit à monsieur paypal après de
nombreux échanges le père conclut alors
à tort que paypal a bloqué le compte de
son fils selon cet expert au pays lit
mineur ont des droits même s'ils mentent
sur leur âge
au québec c'est le code civil qui
s'applique le mineur à partir du moment
où il a fait une dépense qui est jugée
excessive en tenant compte de ses moyens
la dépense elle-même n'était pas
nécessaire pour lui était futile il
pilote un recours pour pouvoir faire
annuler ce genre de transaction l'eau
louis pourrait donc poursuivre aux
petites créances l'entreprise qui lui a
vendu tous les articles virtuels
au bout du compte cette mésaventure lui
a servi de leçon
je dirais pas que c'était inutile dans
votre département lorrain pascal terre
je le suis assez assez très bien l'on
peut dire que tout est fait pour qu'on
dépense ou par courriel paypal précise
qu'elle s'assure de mettre fin à sa
relation avec des clients contrevenants
quand on compte paypal de louis il a
finalement été bloquée à la suite de nos
demandes d'entrevue ici
marie france bélanger radio canada
montréal